(gentle intro music)
Okay so, last pulmonary talk, Pulmonary Potpourri,
there's a lot of things we're gonna discuss here.
Let's go ahead and get started.
Okay, let's start with a question.
This is our same COPD patient from this morning.
So, this is our 52-year-old patient with COPD,
and a 20 pack-year smoking history.
They come in for a comprehensive well visit.
They have successfully quit smoking last year,
after your recommendation,
good job,
and they are otherwise stable, with no other comorbidities.
Which one of the following screening tests for lung cancer
is currently recommended
by the U.S. Preventive Services Task Force?
Please pay very careful attention
to all these Task Force recommendations.
Should we do A., a chest x-ray,
B., a low-dose chest CT now,
C., a low-dose chest CT at age 55,
or D., no screening test is currently recommended?
What do we like in our 52-year-old patient
with a 20 pack-year smoking history?
We all know what a pack-year is, right?
It's the equivalent of smoking a pack a day for a year.
So if you smoked two packs a day for 10 years,
that would be a 20 pack-year history.
Okay, good.
The majority of you got the correct answer,
the second highest plurality
was the previous recommendation,
so you were on the right track, just you weren't updated.
So, let's get into it.
Lung cancer screening.
So, lung cancer is the number one cause
of cancer-related deaths in men and women
above the age of 50.
The death rate is increasing,
the five-year survival rate is unfortunately high,
and 95% of those at risk are not being screened.
How many of us are doing lung cancer screening
in our practices?
Good, it needs to be everyone,
if you're doing outpatient medicine.
Here's the mortality rates of lung cancer,
which bests prostate, breast, and pancreas deaths combined.
Now, David showed a lot of these maps,
I think they're fun too.
This is the lung cancer case rates in the United States.
Definitely the Appalachia, down through the deep south,
is problematic with lung cancer.
And then the next one is lung cancer death rates.
So, it's interesting, you know?
What is happening down through Appalachia and in the south?
Is it socioeconomic?
Is it access to care?
Education?
There's so many ways we could look at this,
but it's very interesting.
Okay, our risks of lung cancer,
smoking is the number one risk factor in this country,
makes up for over 80% of causes,
this could be primary or secondary.
Cigars can be dangerous,
but they don't tend to do as many.
How many of us know what a hookah is?
Hookah?
Yeah, these are really becoming popular with young people.
I live in Detroit,
and Metro Detroit is the second largest Arab community
outside the Middle East,
so my best friend is Arab,
like, hookahs are everywhere,
and they're extremely dangerous,
but they don't think that they are,
because they filter the tobacco through water,
and it's cooled, and flavored,
and they think it's fun.
Vaping, we don't know the risks.
You know, as I mentioned earlier today,
the lungs are just not a good delivery system,
the lungs are very sensitive to damage.
So, have your nicotine,
have at it,
do the patch or the gum,
but the vaping, and the smoking,
and all these things are very dangerous to the lungs.
Don't forget about environmental toxins,
like radon and air pollution,
worse in other countries.
Age, of course, is always a risk factor for lung cancer,
as well as family history.
The presentation, you all know this,
cough, chest pain, dyspnea, hemoptysis.
Clearly.
Now, we divide lung cancer into small cell
and non-small cell, histologically.
So your small cell cancers make up the minority, 10 to 15%,
they tend to occur in a central or mediastinal location,
and there we see it in that left perihilar area.
Unfortunately, they're very aggressive,
and they metastasize early,
and therefore they do confer a poorer prognosis.
The only upside to a fast-growing tumor
is that it is susceptible to chemotherapy,
and that is therefore the primary treatment for small cells.
Non-small cells make up 80%,
the majority of these are adenose.
They typically occur in the periphery,
where you see the box,
often in underlying lung disease.
I mean, this patient looks emphysematous to me,
based on that radiograph.
They're slower growing,
they have a better prognosis,
and therefore surgical resection is the primary treatment.
Now, this is the updated lung cancer screening guidelines
from the U.S. Preventive Services Task Force.
In 2021, they upped the guideline.
It used to be age 55 with a 30 pack-year history, right?
They've lowered it to age 50 with a 20 pack-year history,
'cause they wanna pick up more and more of these cancers.
So, that's a grade B recommendation,
and I believe David mentioned this
earlier in the presentation,
or in the conference, rather,
anytime the U.S. Preventive Services Task Force
gives an A or a B recommendation,
the insurance companies are forced by law to cover them,
they can't say no.
So, yes to lung cancer screening.
Now, Medicare only pays for this up to age 75,
because, you know, the average life expectancy is about 80,
so they tend to cut it off,
even though the Task Force recommends doing it up to 80,
you probably won't get insurance companies to cover it
after age 74.
All right, next question.
Which one of the following diseases is the most common cause
of both secondary hypertension and resistant hypertension?
Is it A., hyperthyroidism?
Is it B., obstructive sleep apnea?
Is it C., pheochromocytoma?
Or D., renal artery stenosis?
I was also asked this question on the boards last year.
Great. Obstructive sleep apnea is the answer.
So, sleep apnea is caused by a collapse
in the soft tissues in the back of the throat.
This occurs when the patient's sleeping,
especially if they're laying on their back,
that results in snoring,
and can also go on to cause apnea and hypopneas.
In the absence of cranial facial abnormalities,
blah blah blah blah blah,
you don't wanna step on any ENT's toes,
generally speaking, everyone with sleep apnea snores,
but not everyone who snores has sleep apnea.
So the risk factors for OSA,
I made it easy for you, OSA.
Obesity, that's the most important risk,
male sex, and age over 40.
So, those are the hallmark risk factors.
The consequences of this can be many,
high blood pressure, as we mentioned,
one of the leading causes of secondary,
as well as resistant, hypertension,
cardiovascular disease, sleep and memory problems,
you know, daytime sleepiness,
they could fall asleep at the wheel and crash their car.
So, this is not just an obnoxious snoring problem.
The symptoms are nocturnal or daytime.
The hallmark are the three S's,
that's snoring, excessive daytime sleepiness,
and significant other complaints.
The partner's like, "You gotta do something.
He's like, stopping breathing when he's in his sleep."
All right.
How about questionnaires?
Yes! The questionnaires, right?
So, we're all gonna do these questionnaires in our office.
My EHR likes the Epworth Sleepiness Scale,
but the STOP-BANG Score actually has better data,
because it has a lot of objective criteria,
including, you know, age, BMI,
neck circumference, gender, and blood pressure.
How do you diagnose it?
Well, you do a sleep study.
If the patient is moderate risk,
you can do a home-based sleep study.
If they're higher risk,
then you need the full polysomnography.
Now, the test is looking for apneas,
which is a lack of breathing for more than 10 seconds,
or hypopnea, with the shallow breathing.
They add these together,
and you get the Apnea-Hypopnea Index,
and this is the money slide.
So AHI between 5 and 14 is mild sleep apnea,
between 15 and 30 is moderate,
greater than 30 is severe.
Those numbers, we need to memorize,
because they have implications for treatment.
The task force in 2022 said
there's inconclusive, insufficient evidence
to assess screening for sleep apnea
in an asymptomatic adult.
So a patient comes in, and they say,
"Oh, you know, I think I might have sleep apnea."
And I'm like, "Well, do you snore?"
"Yes."
"Do you have excessive daytime sleepiness?"
Boom, I'm gonna do the questionnaire,
and see if they meet criteria for a sleep study.
If they don't snore,
and they don't have excessive daytime sleepiness,
they would not be screened.
In 2019, the American Academy of Sleep Medicine
updated their recommendations.
They say if you have high clinical suspicion,
a home-based study should be followed
by a full polysomnography,
if you really think they have sleep apnea,
even despite the negative test.
Or you should repeat the polysomnography
under high clinical suspicion.
You might also wanna repeat a study if something changes.
Maybe they're on Ozempic, and they've lost 50 pounds.
We've seen that in clinical practice,
I've had patients lose over 100 pounds
on these GLP-1 agonists.
If they've had an operative intervention,
if they've had improvement
with their oral mandibular advice,
or if you think they might have central sleep apnea.
Your treatment here, you've got a CPAP,
that's Continuous Positive Airway Pressure.
Again, this is a money slide,
so you're gonna use this for mild or moderate,
I'm sorry, moderate or severe sleep apnea,
or mild, if they have comorbidities.
So if they've got other chronic illnesses going on,
mild sleep apnea qualifies for treatment as well,
so that's important to remember.
There's also Bilevel PAP, that's BiPAP,
and auto-titrating CPAPs.
The next best treatment is an oromandibular advice.
How many of us are familiar with these?
This is a dental appliance,
so, they go to the dentist, they get fitted for it,
they wear it at night,
and it basically forces the mandible forward,
creating more space,
and that improves their sleep apnea.
They tend to be expensive,
they tend to run like a couple thousand,
and I don't know that the insurance companies
always cover them,
but that has the next best data.
Weight loss is definitely essential.
You know, obesity is one of the main risk factors
for this illness,
so if you can get a patient to lose weight,
that can definitely improve their sleep apnea.
The last one, surgical therapy,
the uvulopalatopharyngoplasty,
I love that word, just rolls right off the tongue.
UP3, the otolaryngologists call it,
they're basically rotarying in the back of the throat,
so they're taking out all that extra tissue.
Now, anecdotally,
otolaryngology insists that this is effective,
but we just don't have a clinical study to prove it,
so therefore you're probably not gonna see that option
on the boards.
How many of us are familiar with Inspire?
Inspire's the new kid on the block,
this is basically pacemaker technology,
where they surgically implant a wire
that stimulates the hypoglossal nerve when they're sleeping.
Indications are moderate to severe sleep apnea,
they can't tolerate their CPAP,
they have a low BMI,
because it doesn't work as well in obese patients,
and they have to be at least 18.
So, those patients may qualify for the Inspire therapy.
All right, moving on to another topic.
This topic is one where I think I had three questions,
maybe four, on the boards with this next topic,
so this is a heavy hitter.
Always, always, always pops up on the boards.
So, we have a 25-year-old African-American female.
Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding.
This is important, folks.
Who's involved in a motor vehicle accident,
found to have bilateral hilar infiltrates on chest x-ray.
They are asymptomatic,
and have no history of environmental exposures.
The remainder of the exam is unremarkable.
Pulmonary function testing, PPD, are negative.
Transbronchial biopsy reveals a noncaseating granuloma.
Which one of the following
would be the most appropriate treatment in this case?
So you need to know what the diagnosis is,
now what's the treatment?
A., observation?
B., inhaled long-acting beta2-agonist?
C., inhaled corticosteroid?
Or D., systemic corticosteroids?
What should we do in this patient?
Now, remember, they're asymptomatic,
and this was an incidental finding.
Excellent, good, observation.
Systemic corticosteroids would be the option
if she were symptomatic with her sarcoidosis.
All right, so sarcoid,
systemic granulomatous disease,
we don't really know what causes it,
we think it could be a reaction to some infection,
we're not sure.
There's a slight African-American and younger predominance,
that's why I mentioned the patient
was younger and African-American,
so that will sometimes clue you in.
Patients often present with bilateral hilar adenopathy,
interstitial pulmonary infiltrates,
eye problems, and skin problems.
Pay attention to that.
So you'll see, obviously,
your clinical and radiographic findings,
and then noncaseating epitheloid granulomas.
That is the gold standard
by which you would diagnose sarcoidosis.
Okay, differential?
Well, any atypical pneumonias might present this way,
with, you know, interstitial infiltrates
and hilar adenopathy.
TB.
Lymphoma especially would be on your differential,
that's why you're gonna do a biopsy.
Most patients are asymptomatic,
this can be found on routine radiographs.
About a third have some non-specific symptoms.
If they have sarcoid disease,
90% of them are gonna have lung symptoms,
with cough, dyspnea, and chest discomfort.
In those cases,
you're going to treat with systemic corticosteroids.
In severe cases, you may treat them with cytotoxic agents,
anti-malarials, all sorts of issues,
all the way up to lung and cardiac transplantation.
Now, this next bullet point is important.
I think this is more likely the type of question
you might see on the boards.
You've got a patient with sarcoid,
you know, she might be co-managed by specialties.
She's on prednisone, 20 milligrams a day,
to control her sarcoid.
One thing you have to screen for would be osteoporosis,
because that's one of the sequelae
of long-term corticosteroid use.
Those are the type of questions you're more likely to see
on the boards.
Now, there's several stages of sarcoid.
Stage zero is pretty much normal,
even though they actually have the disease,
the chest x-ray looks fine.
Stage one, you see the bilateral hilar lymph adenopathy.
Stage two, you have that, plus parenchymal infiltrates.
If that progresses to stage three,
they keep the infiltrates, but lose the lymph adenopathy.
And then stage four is fibrotic lung disease.
The worse it is, the lower the likelihood
that they're gonna have spontaneous remission.
So, here's some radiographs.
On the left, Stage I,
you see the hilar lymphadenopathy.
We skip Stage II, into Stage III,
and that's where we get
the bilateral parenchymal infiltrates.
And then if that progresses to Stage IV,
you get pulmonary fibrosis, and that would be incurable.
Early patients may have no symptoms,
later patients, obviously, all sort of things can happen.
This last one I included
because it's popped up on the board every once in a while,
spontaneous remission often occurs
in patients with Lofgren's syndrome,
and that consists of bilateral hilar lymphadenopathy,
ankle arthritis, erythema nodosum,
you know what that looks like from your cocci patient,
fever, myalgia, and weight loss.
So, that's Lofgren's syndrome,
and that's, every now and again, popped up on the boards.
Now, this is important,
extra pulmonary sites.
Granted this is largely a pulmonary disease, right?
But it will next affect the lymph systems.
So, you can see the liver or spleen involvement.
After lungs and lymph, it's ocular.
So, the ocular problem that you will see
is acute anterior uveitis.
I was asked this question on the boards,
and I was also asked the follow-up question,
that it may be asymptomatic,
so a yearly eye exam is now recommended
for your patients with active sarcoid.
Now, if you pay attention to the Q&A session's answers,
I've been giving you supplemental slides,
I'm gonna give you one on this one,
and I'm gonna give you a full ophthalmology set as well.
So, that might be helpful for you,
so tune into that.
And then last would be skin involvement.
Neurosarcoid and cardiac granulomas
are actually fairly rare with sarcoid.
You don't have to treat,
if you do, it's gonna be oral steroids,
usually at a fairly high dose.
Cytotoxic agents, of course, in the worst cases,
the middle bullet point I like,
calcitonin and bisphosphonates
may be useful in preventing osteoporosis.
So that's, again,
the type of question that you could see.
Also, rarely on the boards,
but I have seen it,
some follow ACE levels in the blood
to follow the disease activity.
And that is sarcoid.
I promise you that there will be questions
about sarcoidosis on the exam,
so please know those.
Moving on to granulomatosis with polyangiitis.
We used to call this Wegener's Granulomatosis.
This is a necrotizing granulomatous vasculitis
that affects the respiratory tract and the kidneys,
with focal segmental glomerulonephritis.
We don't know what causes it.
Unlike sarcoid,
this tends to occur more in younger white males.
The symptoms can be respiratory and urine.
You can follow ANCA levels,
and corticosteroids are of course the mainstay
of treatment here.
Clearly, you know,
these patients, you're gonna be consulting pulmonology,
you're gonna be consulting infectious disease,
you're gonna be consulting nephrology.
That's one of the things that drives me crazy
about the boards,
is that a lot of times they expect us to know
these high-end treatments,
when, really, in practical terms,
the answer is, refer to specialty, right?
All right, next question.
You see a previously healthy 60-year-old non-smoker
who consults you for progressive dyspnea and cough.
Vitals are stable,
physical exam is significant for nail clubbing,
decreased breath sounds with bilateral coarse crackles.
You perform office spirometry.
Good for you.
How many do office spirometry?
It's very easy to do. It's simple.
Good.
Which one of the following results on your spirometry
are consistent with a diagnosis of restrictive lung disease?
We already went over obstructive lung diseases,
now let's talk about restrictive.
A., a decreased FVC and TLC with a decreased FEV1 ratio?
B., same decreased FVC and TLC,
but an increase in the FEV1?
C., an increase in the FVC and TLC,
with a decrease in the FEV1?
And D., a increase in the FVC and TLC,
with an increase in the FEV1?
Unfortunately, this isn't one you can sleuth out,
'cause none of 'em have enough in common
that you can make a cross-section.
But if you think about it,
like we talked about what obstructive lung diseases do
with FEV1, right?
And if you think about restrictive lung disease,
everything is restricted,
you don't have the ability to breathe
because of the restrictive process,
which could be intrathoracic or extrathoracic, by the way.
So, you can kind of sleuth this one out just by knowing it.
So, you're going to get both,
both decreased FVC and total lung capacity
are gonna be decreased,
and your FEV1 would be normal, or increased,
as opposed to obstructive,
when it's decreased below 70%, right?
So, that's the right answer.
Good job.
So, this is a heterogeneous set of pulmonary disorders,
all of them cause restrictive patterns.
You have reduced distensibility of the lungs,
that compromises expansion,
so you get reduced lung volumes,
especially your total lung capacity.
So that differentiates them from our obstructive diseases.
This could be, again, like I said,
intrinsic or extrinsic.
The intrinsic causes are, you know,
distal lung parenchymal damage
from all sorts of different disease processes.
Or you could get extrinsic musculoskeletal
neuromuscular disorders,
extreme obesity,
where you just don't have the wall movements.
So, let's take a look.
Your intrinsic causes,
idiopathic pulmonary fibrosis,
sarcoid,
interstitial pneumonias,
organic and inorganic dust exposures,
those are those environmental, occupational lung diseases.
Systemic sclerosis,
pulmonary vasculitis,
radiation therapy,
Langerhans Cell Histiocytosis,
that's formerly called Histiocytosis X.
And then some medications, long-term,
can cause restrictive lung diseases and pulmonary fibrosis.
Your extrinsic causes,
decreased neuromuscular tone from muscular dystrophy,
ALS, polio, et cetera.
Deformations of the rib cage,
where you just can't,
you know, you don't have the capacity.
Decreased space, like pleural effusions,
pneumothorax, ascites, and obesity.
Obesity is on the rise in this country.
You can get obesity hypoventilation syndrome,
formerly called Pickwickian syndrome,
where the weight of the fat is so great
that the patient has a hard time expanding their chest
and breathing.
Okay, so what you're gonna see here,
a decreased TLC and forced vital capacity,
A TLC less than 80% is pathognomonic
for restrictive diseases.
And then we rank them as mild, moderate,
moderately severe, or severe.
This slide, I would try to commit to memory,
it's fairly straightforward,
but these are the spirometric findings that you'll see.
With restrictive patterns,
you're gonna see a decreased FVC and TLC,
with a normal to high FEV1.
With obstructive patterns,
we have a normal FVC and TLC,
but with a decreased FEV1,
'cause it's that breathing through the straw thing
with the obstruction, right?
So, it makes sense when you think about them.
The history and physical here,
obviously the symptoms,
you're gonna have an insidious progression of dyspnea,
it gets worse over time.
And classically, you'll see the three C's,
cough, clubbing of the nails, and crackles on auscultation.
How many of us in clinical practice
have actually seen clubbing?
A good number of you. That's good.
So, let's talk about that.
Here's a picture of nail clubbing.
You see the distal digits look like a club,
so that's literally a descriptive term.
One way you can diagnose it is Schamroth's sign.
So, I want everybody to do this,
take your index fingers, put 'em together,
look at a light source,
and you should see a little diamond in the middle.
That's the gap,
the space between the fingernails.
So you get that divot of about 165 degrees
right there at the union, the lunula,
which is where the nails exit the skin.
If they lose that angle, called the Lovibond angle,
then that obliterates that space,
and you don't have a space.
If anyone does this and doesn't have a space, (laughs)
you better be concerned.
(audience members laughing)
So, that's how you diagnose nail clubbing.
Now, the treatment, it varies.
Immunosuppressive drugs,
you know, it's not easy to treat restrictive lung diseases,
a lot of times it's symptomatic,
and a lot of times they have a poor outcome.
And we are done with pulmonology.
Y'all have done great.
(audience applauding)
(gentle outro music)